Mark Ellis here on the street at
WonderCon courtesy of Rotten Tomatoes
talking all things Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is going to hit theaters
soon so let's see what folks we're
excited about this is the end of the
road let's make it count
[Music]
I'm so excited but I'm kind of nervous
at the same time go see that finale it's
going to be amazing it's the last of the
Guardians and there's an otter in the
trailer so I'm looking forward to Lady
Lila Sabrina Cosmo from The Jetsons no
the dog I was thinking of Astro
I was way off Guardians is my personal
favorite in the MCU but also Rocket's my
favorite Guardian Rocket Raccoon gets a
little salty with the language though
are you cool with that he's trying to
save the Galaxy so you know I'm not
going to fall to for a little I swear
once in a while I want to see one of
them die
[Music]
person on the guardian
guard they're all on the same table I
really do hope that a lot of the
characters you know continue on in some
form I'm picking Groot he's already died
one so he can come back that blue chick
nebula feel like Drax is gonna die I
don't want anybody because I love Rocket
the Raccoon I think we're gonna see
rocket kind of make an ultimate
sacrifice in this one for his family
rocket might be the one who might die I
don't think Rocket's gonna make it out
I'm a little worried about him so I just
I need answers no we need him in our
lives he's so cute and fluffy we're
gonna keep rocket they better keep
rocket why is everybody picking Rockets
you don't kill the dog does that
translate to Raccoon if we're calling
him a trash Panda absolutely and
everyone's gonna cry over a raccoon that
everyone in the first film was like oh
we want to see a movie with a raccoon in
a tree now everyone's gonna cry over
that raccoon
[Music]
thank you
I'm a huge Star-Lord fan I like to keep
the party going I'm a Peter Quill guy
Star-Lord why do you like Star Wars
because he can dance
c3po's got some moves glute I would say
Groot this little guy he got off in the
first movie he doesn't deserve to be off
again probably Gamora she's amazing
rocket
raccoon I like that little Rocket
Raccoon guy with all his little weapons
he makes good use of them I gotta say
he's not around anymore but rip to yondu
gotta appreciate that one up over there
especially considering Peter Quill
didn't have much of a traditional
childhood when you wake up in the
morning and you look at yourself in the
mirror are you an antagonist are you a
protagonist
I'm a king
[Music]
Captain America and the Winter Soldier
it should be winter soldier I would say
Spider-Man no way home it's an Infinity
War Infinity War final answer probably
end game because it was kind of like the
big finale but I don't think it's that
because of that reason I'm gonna say end
game end game that's what I'm gonna say
so close it's two on the Tomato Meter
the number one MCU movie is Black
Panther from 2018 and then Avengers end
game and Spider-Man no way home
thanks for stopping by y'all enjoy the
rest of your WonderCon
I am Groot I know who you are already
thanks for joining us for on the street
here from WonderCon and Anaheim
California Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
hitting theater soon so comment right
now and let us know who's your favorite
Guardian who do you need to make it out
of this movie alive and when are you
going to see the movie in theaters like
subscribe and until next time I'm Mark
Ellis see you on the street and after
you see Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
make sure you rate and review at
rottentomatoes.com who can squat more
Incredible Hulk or draft definitely hope
you're the tallest person I've ever
interviewed how does that feel nice
that's cool with great power comes great
responsibility